[Musique]
khabbach du 20 décembre à paris dans un
lieu mythique de la capitale la maison
de la mutualité
le conseil départemental est venu
réchauffer les coeurs des réunionnais
d'ile-de-france un moment rempli
d'émotion car derrière les vibrations
des rouleurs et des kayamb celle annonce
de l'abolition de l'esclavagé qui
résonne alors il s'en retourne prend son
dalon bleus mais sur son épaule et se
met à courir de toutes ses forces
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la liberté
il
ça cogne dans le coeur ça cogne
voilà ça donne quand même roulé ça
secoue comme un caillou ça ça fait
bouger ça fait bouger ça vous touche en
fait d'être d'être ici pour le 20
décembre 15h30 des centaines d'invités
viennent en famille participer à
l'événement le froid n'a pas entamé leur
motivation
les portes s'ouvrent aux abords de la
salle une exposition sur l'histoire de
l'esclavagé
pour ne pas oublier que la fête kaf est
d'abord une commémoration c'est notre
mémoire qui est en jeu et donc on
continue de vivre c'est cette pression
donc en nous on est à paris
à paris où victor schoelcher a fait
voter l'abolition de l'esclavagé
donc avec l'ensemble des associations
réunionnaises à paris c'est important
pour nous d'être avec eux en tant qu'élu
représentant bien sûr la présidente du
département madame nassimah dindar pour
célébrer ce moment fort qui lie tous les
réunions
et à cette libération et à cette fête de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé quand qayomi
sags rennais pour rouleur il a roulé et
ben c'est notre coeur et ça vibre et je
déclare le kava du 20 décembre
mille deux cents invités trois concerts
des animations et des billets d'avion
offerts par la compagnie réunionnaise
la fête démarre enfin jean françois
pounoussamy leader de jf gang réveille
les amendes ans et qui a un cancer d'un
réunionnais ou d'un confrère
je vais voir ça me fait du bien et
continue à faire du bien aux réunionnais
qui sont dehors voilà ça amène de la
chaleur c'est bon set up
davy sicard transporte la salle à dix
mille kilomètres de là entre souvenirs
carrie et grand sourire pour la bonne
humeur difficile de ne pas rire devant
maroni transformé pour l'occasion en
miss planète pulpeuse
le rouleur de mjp tradition continue de
battre la cadence et de faire monter la
pression avant l'annoncé des deux
gagnants du vol paris la réunion de
damas a promis par madame sigismeau
merci beaucoup on a aussi dit mot je
remercie énormément le conseil général
qui m'a permis de faire mes études à
paris et là ça fait trois ans je suis
pas autant d ali de la réunion parce que
j'ai dû économiser j'avais des problèmes
financiers et je suis vraiment ému
heureuse merci beaucoup
sur scène le traditionnel boeuf musical
annonce la fin du kabar dans un tonnerre
d'applaudissements c'est un grand
plaisir
j'espère que l'on va continuer comme ça
et ont ramené un peu le maloya le titre
très belle soirée avec
beaucoup de mal aux ya beaucoup de
de ferveur donc on va descendre tous les
réunionnais dernière surprise des sacs à
dos remplis de samoussas et de litchi
pour affronter en douceur l'hiver
parisien dans la tête
le son du rouleur résonne encore
[Musique]